hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video dadurch hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt heute habe ich mal
wieder was ganz anderes vor
ich saß solutions for pc hab überlegt
okay was für videos kann man noch machen
und irgendwie hat man manchmal dann so
eine kreative phase oder was heißt
kreative phase so kreatives ist jetzt
auch nicht aber das gibt's doch nicht
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
machen was heute mal und zwar aber
nachts guckt also in köln zumindest gibt
es nur noch ich habe das auch irgendwann
selbst mal einem video gesagt gibt es
noch zwei anbieter für essen und zwar
einmal lieferant das kann ja
wahrscheinlich jeder vielleicht das gibt
es ja überall in deutschland und dann
haben wir noch der lippe ruhe und ich
muss sagen ich bestell mittlerweile
eigentlich lieber bei der lippe wo
einfach war in meiner meinung nach da
bessere anbieter sind bevor wir jetzt
aber wieder irgendwann wieder machen wie
ein stern der hose des 5 sterne oder
pizza da wo es pizza okay das machen wir
heute
weil also im ersten part hiervon geht es
um das schlechteste essen von lieferando
wo es ist das schlechteste essen von
cilic also ich bestelle halt gleich
einmal da das schlechteste und daraus
vielleicht das ist ja logisch und dann
schauen wir einfach mal was da ankommt
und was besser ist ja ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher das komplett in ganz
deutschland und auch diese beiden
lieferservice lieferservice server
computer live services wie voip services
würde diese beiden lieferservices
existieren falls nicht korrigiert mich
sehr gerne in den kommentaren
aber die verrate hat alles aufgekauft so
toren so das gibt's ja gar nicht mehr
dann würde ich sagen wir daran gar nicht
schlagen ich setz dich mal kurz hin
auf diesem stuhl wir ein bisschen
wackeln und habe in meinem macbook
mitgenommen übrig bleiben so leute ich
hab mal nach bewertung gefiltert wir
gehen mal ganz nach unten und das
schlechteste ich habe eben schon mal
kurzerhand ein dünner und kleber jetzt
erst mal auf ich fand das wirklich
heftig kann man das halt ein stern und
die bewertungen sind alle meine
bestellung ist nicht angekommen essen
nicht angekommen nicht bestellen essen
kommt nicht an der laden nicht existiert
und die nummer ebenfalls nicht asozial
so da muss man sich mal
wieso gibt es also weiß das wird ja
anscheinend wirklich so sein wieso gibt
es dann diesen anbietern auch deswegen
wir wollen ja auch wirklich essen
bekommen
bestellen wir woanders wird immer das
schlechteste was ich jetzt hier gefunden
habt trattoria casa mia hat auch eine 3
bewertungen der salat kam mit meist
bleibe klar dass schnitzel war eine
frechheit pizza war schon kalt und hart
nie wieder hat eine bewertung von zwei
sternen okay ich habe jetzt einfach ganz
dumm von margherita bestellt und noch so
ein nudelgericht und das bestelle ich
mal eben okay leute die erste bestellung
ist vollendet wir haben elf auf 50
bezahlt diese pizza irgendwelche nudeln
und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die lippe
hier ich habe die app auf dem handy das
irgendwie viel entspannter deswegen
nehme ich jetzt einfach mal kurz zum
bildschirm auf aber jetzt habe ich mich
hier gerade auf insgesamt agiert können
immer gern folgen heisst alex wie ok
sortieren nach am besten bewertet fertig
und hier gibt es dann so sachen die
haben nicht mal eine bewertung was ich
schon super dubios finde passiert halt
3,6 und ist das schlechteste zu nehmen
also leute hier gibt es eine menge
restaurants haben einfach gar keine
bewertung und wir haben uns jetzt mal
darauf geeinigt dass wir aber dass er
mit der schlechtesten bewertung und das
hat sogar 3,6 ist auch so ähnlich wie
das wo ich vorgestellt habe also da gibt
es die gleichen sachen deswegen warum
nicht guck mal da steht italienisch das
erste was mir angezeigt wird bratwurst
als ich hier jetzt so viel essen das
finde ich auch schon immer so ein
bisschen komisch wenn die indisch
mexikanisch japanisch fisch schnitzel
currywurst okay aber hauptsache der name
ist da vinci okay zum warenkorb
da muss man hier lange opitz an rieter
um 14 eur 20 1 euro über gebühr zur
kasse gehen und bestellung abschicken
so leute ich habe stellt
voraussichtliche ankunft 14 und 40 die
müssen ungefähr gleich an kommen also
jetzt heißt es warten
was glaubst du wird besser sein ich
glaube nicht lieferung mein zulieferern
ist besser
weil eine sagt hat ihn natürlich super
interessant ist wir haben bei den summen
wirklich ein restaurant was absolut
schlecht bewertet ist und das bei intel
immer wo war gar nicht mal so schlecht
was das ergebnis sein wird erfahren wir
gleich wir sehen uns gleich wieder
abonniert in der zeit main kanal neue
hessen ist da okay leute wir haben hier
jetzt zwei mal essen man muss sagen ist
zum verwechseln ähnlich ich habe mich
dann ein bisschen gefragt also wie
gesagt ich bin mir mittlerweile ich
bestelle beide lupu einfach weil ich das
besser finde und schmeckt immer besser
und normalerweise kriegt man die sachen
da in so einer kleinen tüte ich weiß es
nicht vielleicht liegt das ja weil die
plätze zu groß ist dass man es nicht in
dieser tüte bekommen hat ich finde halt
die lippen wirkt auf mich immer so ein
bisschen hochwertiger deswegen ist auch
ein bisschen teurer und fällt meistens
eine liefer gebühr von 2 bis 5 euro an
ok also das heißt vorinformationen jetzt
haben wir hätten mit einer bewertung von
3,6 und hier lieferant mit einer
bewertung von 20 14 eur 11 euro ja also
preis nicht die frage ist jetzt
natürlich womit ich anfangen ich würde
aber sagen wir fangen mit dem teureren
an also das jetzt 14 euro kostet dann
kommt passiert erstmal zur seite
hier haben wir die margherita polizei
also ich muss sagen sieht also ich
relativ standard aus schon ein bisschen
kalt hier unten oder die fähigkeit der
firma geht geht also ich hatte auf jeden
fall schonmal wärmere liefer pizza und
hier haben wir dann die nudeln napoli
genau
für die rechten ultra komisch spricht
ich finde diesen fall also ich komme ja
vom land die richter nebels nach
landluft nicht mehr fußmatte nicht der
fußmatte diesmal nenne ich möchte aber
die fußmatte die fußballer aber okay ich
heute erst mal gar ich würde mal sagen
wir fangen mit der pizza an weil da kann
man ja eigentlich am wenigsten falsch
machen
ich finde hier ansicht ganz lecker aus
der käse ja weil sie nicht ich probiere
einfach mal
täglich kommen hier auch die nun die
richtung
sorry dass man sollte nicht über essen
reden aber die recht erheblich ich muss
aber zu pizza sagen dir ist lecker
schmeckt auch echt gut also 2,0 sterne
schmeckt für mich anders
[Musik]
guttenberg muss man hier an die nudeln
ich weiß nicht was da drin ist
[Musik]
unschwer ich hab noch nie so schlecht
gegessen
ich sage ich nur auf die besser machen
warum vielleicht schmeckt auf deine
verantwortung ich bin ja auch so jemand
meine lieblings pizzas eigentlich pizza
mit spaghetti ich finde das ist eine
richtig gute mischung müsst ihr mal
probieren wir das tor nicht gemacht habt
[Musik]
die nudeln die machen deshalb komplett
da und die pizza ist in ordnung die
norwegian katastrophe die griechen komik
und schnecken aus so allofs hat wie kann
ich gar nicht empfehlen wir haben sechs
euro gekostet naja leute mir ist gerade
ein kleiner fehler passiert da die
sachen total gleich aussehen ich hab mir
am anfang gesagt wir fangen mit dem
teureren an das hier war der in rudy
pizza ist super g nudeln waren absolut
grausam
das hat insgesamt 14 euro gekostet
meiner meinung nach viel zu viel und
jetzt schauen wir mal was wir hier haben
das ist nur mit lieferando hier haben
wir die 3,6 sterne bewertungen wir haben
wir nur die zwei sterne bewertung und ob
das jetzt noch schlechter ist als dass
das finden wir heraus öffnen die pizza
gehst du geschnitten und ich muss hier
sagen schaut euch mal diese pizza an
dies komme ich finde dass da sieht man
direkt welche qualitativ hochwertiger
ist oder diese hier sie voll billig aus
und diese hier sieht aus wie eine gute
pizza aus dem restaurant finde ich ich
würde die feier echt ok also ich finde
diese hier sind meist aus
ich finde es auch besser wenn pfizer so
ein bisschen dünner ist aber gut also
hier haben wir die marke vita in
kombination 11 eur liefere
ich möchte ihnen die nacht sind ja erst
mal probiert ich fand dich mal ich finde
ich total komisch auch also meiner
meinung nach sieht diese pizza wirklich
besser aus als die schmeckt aber noch
schlechter als die wobei wir diese hier
von der lippe roja eigentlich als gut
abgestempelt haben also lieber in
ordnung die hier sieht nice haus
schmeckt aber nicht gut
es kommen wir als letztes noch zu den
nudeln und hier muss ich eigentlich
sagen die können nur besser schmecken
als die weil das man wirklich oder spaß
die schlechteste die ich je in meinem
leben irgendwo gegessen habe außer ich
hab selber gekocht dann wird es noch
schlechter aber hier geht es ja uns
gestellt vivat immer wenn er den
unterschied
ich habe spaghetti napoli bestellt oder
pasta napoli okay ist ja auch egal
ich finde eigentlich sogar diese nudeln
auch ganz prima da alter diese hier die
griechen einfach nur nach kuka kündigte
jetzt an den diesen guten ja besser auf
jeden fall besser also wenn an dieser
kamera ist ein richtig funktionieren
werde ich würde sterben schlechtesten
die veränderungen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass die
schlechter sind als die aber wie
schmecken halt einfach noch nichts
man schmeckt 0 soße die schnecken nur
nach frühling und die nudeln sind so
richtig weiß also die brechen im mund
auseinander
also heute hatten wir pech ich habe ja
eigentlich gedacht okay den lippen russ
immer teurer
lieferanten günstiger vielleicht haben
wir eine überraschung und das überzeugt
total und das ist egal ich das ende vom
lied ist der lenovo hat nicht heute nun
überzeugt lieferando aber ganz viel an
auch weniger das einzige was man gut
essen kann ist die pizza war ein
interessantes experiment mit einem
interessanten ergebnis trotzdem habe ich
noch vor ein paar andere sachen zu
testen wie zb den besten burger von den
besten werken von lieferando oder keine
ahnung treppe ideen in die kommentare
das mit dem video jetzt gibt es jeden
abend um 19 uhr ein video für euch
abonniert den kanalinseln last nur nach
oben da